hey this is presh talwalker
Elaine runs perpendicular to a road that
is 64 feet wide
it is just possible to carry a pole 125
feet long from the lane into the road
while keeping the pole horizontal
what is the minimum width of the lane in
feet
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
let's break down the problem and solve
it step by step
we will first sketch a diagram that
corresponds to the problem
so first we will sketch a lane and then
we will sketch a road that's
perpendicular to it
the road is 64 feet wide and let's say
the lane is L feet wide
it is just possible to carry a poll 125
feet long from the lane into the road
so imagine we have a pole that's 125
feet long and we're trying to take it
from the lane into the road
so we'll carry it this way and then
we'll hit the wall so we'll rotate it
and then we're gonna have to try and
squeeze it in this corner so we're given
that the pole just fits between these
two So eventually we're going to have
the following Condition it's going to
touch the corner between the lane and
the road and it's going to touch the
boundary of the lane and the road
so we know the pole is 125 feet long so
we'll need this information to solve for
L the minimum length of the width of the
lane
so how can we do that
well let's just focus on this diagram
we now have a right triangle where the
pole is the hypotenuse
to continue we will break down this
right triangle into two smaller right
triangles
extend this part of the road so that it
meets the lane this leg of this right
triangle will have length equal to l
then we will extend the lane until it
meets the boundary of the road and this
leg will have a length that's equal to
64.
suppose the pole makes an angle of theta
with the lane
since the two boundaries of the lane are
parallel to each other this angle here
will also be equal to Theta
now suppose this triangle has a
hypotenuse equal to H1
we can then say that sine Theta is equal
to l divided by H1
we can solve this equation for H1 to get
H1 is equal to l divided by sine Theta
now in this other right triangle we can
do a similar calculation
let's suppose this hypotenuse length is
equal to H2 now cosine of theta is equal
to 64 divided by H2 we can solve this
for H2 to get that H2 is equal to 64
divided by cosine Theta
now H1 plus H2 will be the length of the
pole which is 125.
so we have the equation H1 plus H2
equals 125 and we can substitute in for
H1 and H2 L divided by sine theta plus
64 divided by cosine Theta is equal to
125.
so now let's just focus on this equation
let's solve this equation for l
subtract 64 over cosine Theta from both
sides
then multiply both sides of the equation
by sine Theta
we now have sine Theta over cosine Theta
which is equal to tangent Theta so L is
equal to 125 sine Theta minus 64 tangent
Theta
this is the condition when the pull is
exactly on the boundary of the lane
touching the corner and touching the
boundary of the road
now we need the minimum required length
for all values of theta
so we need to maximize this function
over Theta
that'll give us the minimum required
length
so we have a function of theta so let's
find any critical points
we'll take the derivative so L Prime is
equal to 125 cosine Theta minus 64
multiplied by 1 over cosine squared
theta
we'll set this equal to zero
let's now multiply both sides of this
equation by cosine squared theta to get
that 0 is equal to 125 cosine cubed
Theta minus 64. then we can solve for
cosine cubed Theta
we get 64 is equal to 125 cosine cubed
Theta or cosine cubed Theta is equal to
64 over 125 which equals 4 cubed over 5
cubed
we want Theta to be between 0 and 90
degrees so we'll just take the positive
cube root here
so if cosine Theta is equal to 4 over 5
that's the critical value
now from here we need to solve for sine
Theta and tangent Theta because that's
what we have our equation for l in terms
of
so to do that we'll sketch a right
triangle
we have an angle Theta here let's say
that the leg here is 4 and the
hypotenuse is five so cosine Theta is
equal to four over five
this is clearly a three four five right
triangle so we can solve the other leg
is equal to three
we now solve that sine Theta is equal to
three over five and tangent Theta is
equal to three over four
we go back to our equation that L is
equal to 125 sine Theta minus 64 tangent
Theta and substitute in for sine and
tangent and we get that L is equal to 27
feet and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign